some pretty insane expectations i hope
tonight reminds you
why you love to play games and with that
we're going to move on to our first game
with a game that was just announced
yesterday call of duty black ops cold
war
and joining me is dan vondrack from
raven to tell us about the game and give
you an exclusive sneak peek
dan how you doing
good jeff thanks for having me here this
is uh been a dream project for us to
work on from the from nearly the
beginning of development
we knew black ops cold war was going to
be a direct sequel to black ops 1
and we loved the idea of returning to
the pillars
built the black ops franchise deniable
operations conspiracy ground and history
and that shadowy world of paranoia and
we get to mix
all those together drop the player into
the 1980s at the height of the cold war
and it's really something that we know
would feel relevant to today and also
uniquely black ops
well you start playing with black ops
everyone wants to know
characters we saw yesterday in the
reveal trailers you know some familiar
faces so
you know woods mason like break it down
um how does this fit into the black op
cans you said it's a direct sequel so
are we gonna see a lot of familiar faces
yeah part of the fun of making this game
was bringing back the iconic characters
like woods and hudson and mason
and seeing how all those personalities
mixed with some of the new characters
so the campaign takes place in 1981 and
we love that we've been able to have so
many connections to the original black
ops and really be that direct sequel to
the game
uh now one thing that i'm really excited
about this is you're
pushing the storytelling in kind of a
new direction with some branches and
some options about how you play through
the campaign can you maybe walk us
through your thinking there
yeah one of the driving forces from
early in development was to say let's
take this black ops thrill ride
and infuse it with some player choice
and some player freedom anything we can
do to give the player a little more
ownership over their experience
so that starts with allowing the player
to create their own character for the
cold war campaign
they can name them and pick a military
background and really pretend they are
that black ops soldier that they want to
be
from there we wanted to take some of our
missions and infuse
optional objectives multiple paths and
some player choice moments
inside some of those missions and it was
fun to find that balance between the
hard driving call of duty action
and these more non-linear experiences
and some inside some of the missions
so with choice comes the player wanting
to feel that
impact so some of those choices earlier
in the game and some towards the end
will actually shape the ending of the
narrative
of the campaign all right so multiple
endings to this game
yeah absolutely absolutely that's that
was one of the big things for us it's
like we love that black ops has always
been willing to take risks and we all
know
they did some of this in black ops 2 and
with our story and with these features
we love playing homage to those early
black ops games
oh yeah i remember the numbers all right
uh well dan
we are excited to see more of it i know
multiplayer reveal is coming in
september but
uh since you got a switch there maybe
you could flip the switch on something
exclusive for us
what are you going to show us
yeah absolutely this is really exciting
because this will be the first time
this outside the walls of the
development studio
this is the scene from earlier in the
game and it's a critical point that
really shows the narrative of the world
shows this threat that our heroes are
going to be battling
so let's take a look
1943 detailed information from the
manhattan project was stolen from los
alamos by the russian spy known as
perseus
1968 vietnam war
vietcon soldiers orchestrated by perseus
attempted to steal an american-made
nuclear bomb from a u.s
firebase five days ago while on a
mission
we acquired intel that perseus is in
play again
and planning an attack on the west
perseus the cia's analysts consider him
to be the single
largest threat to the free world
mr hudson we're all aware of perseus
we're also aware he's more myth than
fact i mean
personally i think he's nothing more
than the russian boogeyman
general hague allow me to introduce the
man
as suited to respond to that cia
clandestine special officer russell
adler
he's one of the few people even come
close to capturing
uh mr adler why should we take this
perseus threat seriously you don't have
to sir
yeah then a lot of innocent people are
gonna die why do you say that
sir every time perseus has come into
play it's shifted the balance of the
cold war
after 13 years of silence if he's active
something big is gonna happen something
that will affect the free world
[Music]
mr president sir mr president mr
president this is jason hudson and
russell
i know their names who do you think
approve their
last mission
is the threat real yes sir we believe it
is
can you stop perseus we can sir i've
already submitted the requisition for my
team
sir their requests are highly irregular
most likely illegal if the press gets
old what the hell are you talking about
you know who we are every mission we go
on is illegal
sergeant woods plausible deniability is
the backbone of our work
ah we're talking about preventing an
attack on the free men and women of the
world
give mr adler whatever he wants
gentlemen
you've been given an important task
protecting our very way of life from a
great evil
there is no higher duty there is no
higher honor
and while few people will know of your
struggles
rest assured the entire free world
will benefit i know you won't fail us
tonight we have some new game
announcements for you guys as well
including this